coughing sneezing runny nose it might
feel like another case of the cold but
enterovirus 68 is sending hundreds of
children to hospitals in severe cases
kids who contract the illness have
difficulty breathing and are placed on a
ventilator within hours and because it's
a virus antibiotics don't work so why
are children hit hardest and Toro virus
is spread through contact with the nose
or mouth similar to the cold or flu and
because they're in such close physical
contact at school kids are more at risk
but adults can get it as well it's
pretty scary but in most cases it's not
deadly subscribe on YouTube follow us on
Twitter and like us on Facebook